President Trump in a triumphant mood
while Democrats reeling from the fallout
over the Iowa caucuses the president
boasting about his impeachment acquittal
while attacking Speaker Nancy Pelosi I
think there's a lot of evil on that side
they've gone crazy
they've got totally crazy should they
expunge the impeachment in the house
they should because it was a hoax it was
a total political hoax I thought it was
a terrible thing when she ripped up the
speech first of all it's an official
document you're not allowed it's illegal
what she did she broke the law
the president also mocking Democrats
over how the Iowa caucuses were handled
by understands the votes are fried in
Iowa they they couldn't even take a
simple tabulation and yet they're
telling you how to run the country and
how to run healthcare I have no idea who
won they have no idea but I'll tell you
who won for the Republican side they
accounted for every single vote and it
was a lot of votes was a record-setting
number of votes Trump won hmm while
President Trump tries to capitalize off
the Iowa Democrats chaos the Democratic
Party is headed for a big divided
election forecaster Nate Silver is
giving Bernie Sanders a 50-50 shot at
winning the entire game the party's
nomination many Democrats they're not
happy about that including Hillary
Clinton yes vote for the person that you
believe can actually win in November and
the person who you think can govern our
country but you've got to be responsible
for what you say and what you say you're
going to do we need to rebuild trust in
our fellow Americans and in our
institutions and if you promise the moon
and you can't deliver the moon then
that's gonna be one more indicator of
how you know we just can't trust each
other I don't know where it's our God
honestly that didn't make any sense
sorry it makes sense she doesn't like
Bernie Sanders no I get it I just I
really uh you know I try to be really
nice okay so don't be nice stay with the
home
thus out of five this isn't Fox and
Friends when she's talking I'm like I
really don't see her landing any point
it's just the same thing you've been
hearing since 2008 really when she ran
against Barack Obama and lost in that
primary and then with the Bernie Sanders
thing I just the Democrats have had such
a bad week that I bet all the coverage
this morning it was like I was I wasn't
really enjoying myself but David Brooks
for example and then New York Times
writes are Democrats trying to throw
away our Democrats going to throw away
an election you have James Carville in
voxcom do yourself a favor go there read
the interview that he does it is
priceless in which he says we are in a
terrible state and then you have
Jonathan you hate when he says the F
words
yeah that's a good part I'm gonna do
that I'm gonna join the next block okay
so you gotta stick around for that then
Jonathan Chait who writes at New York
magazine he's like we actually are in
such bad shape that we might look back
at this week and think it was the high
point of the election so it's not that
just that the Republicans are saying the
Democrats are having a bad week mcdonnen
Brazil was just on with Bill Hemmer she
says that was embarrassing
in Iowa on Tuesday night that it's just
bad I think America needs a weekend know
yeah the Democrats need a weekend
America needs a way I need a weekend oh
well I'll tell you I tell you who
doesn't seem to be quite as happy as you
would think is Donald Trump Pete baby he
says he wants Nancy Pelosi in the house
to expunge the impeachment he's still
fuming no I actually came on the show
tonight want to check on your health
thank you thank you
okay come join us on Fox and Friends to
the weekend weekend we'll still be
talking about the best week ever
remember that show like that's Mike
that's Mike that's what I'm doing
tomorrow night
all right vh1 best week ever absolutely
for the president he he has his own
style and way of spiking the football
but when you look at the State of the
Union the acquittal 49% on Gallup
approval rating up from 39 since the
think holes start this thing started
94 percent GOP approval 90% of people
are satisfied with their personal life
ya know president Trump copyrighted for
that except for Greg Gutfeld 225
thousand jobs added the lieutenant Carl
Levin Minh
fired this is this is the white house
totally undeterred by someone who why
would you want that guy inside your
white house and so and then you turn to
the Democrats and say when you've got
your former nominee who couldn't win
claiming that they need to nominate
someone who can win and then you've got
the guy you've got the new frontrunner
is the mayor of the 4th largest town in
Indiana this is as bad of a moment as
Democrats have had and not we're talking
all about Iowa look at Milwaukee where
the top aides for the convention have
now resigned and said we can't even
handle the convention that's coming in
how many months from now and a four or
five it's a disastrous I don't know that
they were Democrats but but let me just
say this do you think that things will
change once there's a democratic now how
many all this vindictive behavior by the
president like you know people will say
a percent chance that they nominate a
socialist who's not even a Democrat and
that's from the New York Times who the
last person they want is Bernie Sanders
but wait a sec how does it change I
think I think Trump would very much like
to face Bernie Sanders I agree are you
agree all right so you know one of the
things that's been puzzling me is Trump
says you know Russian interference is a
hoax but aren't you isn't anybody
concern that the Russians are still
interfering and they might do it I don't
get this is what he comes out and says
today it's like it's like nothing ever
happened nothing changes nothing really
does nothing really changes Ron yeah and
I think to borrow one of Hillary
Clinton's phrases in that really odd
speech you know when you promised the
moon and then you can't deliver that's
what's been happening in this entire
time the Democrats to me about you know
they've always been we talk about this
all the time they're pushing the goal
they're moving the football they're
saying oh it's it's the Muller
investigation it's Russia
it's impeachment it's this and now
they've messed up Iowa they messed up
the State of the Union this is not an
isolated event everything that occurs
they make fools of themselves and to me
they're like zombies running around
eating each other and pointing fingers
and then trying to drag us into it so
now for example we have the Iowa
congresswoman saying look Tom Prez you
should resign then we have him blaming
the Iowa State or a Democrat saying that
this debacle is their fault at every
part of the way they are pointing
fingers at each
or pointing fingers at Trump without
offering any type of solutions we have
nothing to show for it as citizens who
have benefited not at all from this and
they have nothing to show for it because
that they are continuing to reveal
themselves as inept laughingstocks
Wow okay Greg what you were had a strong
reaction to Hillary um no I want to talk
about well first I want to talk about
Iowa saying it's in disarray
it's like saying the Grand Canyon is a
hole this is really really bad we always
talk about this was their first day of
school and they showed up wearing their
dad's golf bag with their mom's wedding
dress over it there's something
seriously irrevocably wrong about it
Trump we're talking about Trump's
victory lap we deserve a victory lap
because we were put through what two
months of this crap thing six months of
all of this crap I yelled at the
producers every day about the hearings
no the Democrats should be apologizing
to our producers because I kept yelling
at the producers not to because because
the hearings they were it was like
watching people with constipation eating
bran see so the battery lab should be
not just Trump but it should be
everybody who had to be put through this
charade
lastly the big picture the contrast okay
the contrast between the Republican
Party whose numbers in appeal are
growing and the Democratic Party whose
numbers are going down right now you got
three metrics for the Republican Party
you have jobs which are soaring
you got satisfaction which is soaring
you got wages which are going up okay
what are the what is what are the
Democrats counteroffer division
impeachment race-baiting cancel culture
going after people are in their own
party for saying the wrong thing they're
pitting identity groups against each
other
it's a hateful hateful place the
Democratic Party was supposed to be
about compassion and love and they're
eating themselves alive you have you
have Liz Warren blaming America for her
toxic work culture I mean it's a joke
you guys Nick what's-his-face the
southerner dude you were talking about
Alan Carvel he's so right
he's so right he's trying to save his
own party the thing is there's no mercy
rule in politics so when you ask are
things going to change when there's a
nominee like if you're winning you just
want to keep winning okay wait a second
you know who's winning hmm Bernie
Sanders right again go to Jack Joe Biden
all beat
Trump right now nobody's winning I'm
just telling over once you get a nominee
this was what I was saying the Dana once
you get a nominee this dynamic shifts
and all of those people if they were the
nominee right now would beat Donald now
you can't ignore that court case today
you guys that was a significant
development and yes it was on standing
but the fact that the the DC Circuit the
Federal Court of Appeals ruled in
Trump's favor and said hey Democrat hey
you glow makers you can't sue the
president in court over the emoluments
clause remember that was another huge
talking point from the Democrats for the
last three years that failed also it's
one more thing maybe they're in a
weekend they need a drink yeah I like
the I wanted to keep going let's just go
straight through the money we gotta go
we got another segment you can keep
coming all right